[Music]
okay you guys I am so excited I can
barely stand it we have two incredible
guests coming up and you're not gonna
believe it please
please confer Hillary
and
welcome
[Applause]
thank you
oh my gosh hello
something normal up thank you for being
here Chelsea Clinton yeah you're a
global Health scholar humanitarian
activist teacher and vice chair of the
Clinton foundation and on top of all
that you're a best-selling children's
book author Hillary Clinton yeah damn
right woo
foreign
[Applause]
Clinton you are here because you have
been the first lady a U.S senator the
Secretary of State and the first female
Presidential nominee of a major American
political party and the winner of the
mother popular vote thank you
friends
freaking thrilled to have you here oh
what a boon and congratulations on your
third season
letting me on my third season
[Applause]
you know what
to celebrate I might have a margarita
did you make that one yourself
um you are a globally known margarita
maker thank you that could be in your
biography Amber Ruffin host of the
annivers show and Global and globally
recognized Margarita renowned yes I mean
that's me and that's what this show is
about so Margaret not just kidding guys
you both have an amazing new show on
Apple TV plus it's called gutsy now on
that show you interview real life gutsy
women so it's surreal to have you here
in my studio but not as surreal as it
was to have you in my actual house guys
I interviewed you uh you guys
interviewed me yes yes I did yes well it
was a conversation like you also sort of
interviewed us while we were
interviewing you yes it was the coolest
thing that has ever happened to me and I
started it off by embarrassing myself
horribly so let's all reenact it
freaking minding my own business these
two people come to my house
so
much of my house there's three pictures
right mommy daddy husband's mommy daddy
and this drawing that my husband grew of
us
this is the drawing
there it is now this drawing is a joke
he drew because he I thought was kissing
me in an inappropriate way in public
he brought the inappropriateness into
your voice yes and then framed it and
put it in the hallway I laughed when I
pass it I don't laugh when I have to
explain it to Hillary Clinton so yeah so
now we can all feel bad for me
oh my gosh okay so I've been watching
all of gutsy it's fantastic it's very
bingeable dangerously bingeable
um so on that show uh you guys met a
million amazing women including Megan
the stallion so
heard away
pretty great so Chelsea you're a fan of
hers I am okay and you introduced your
mom to her music so when I listened to
the album it made me blush what was it
like playing it for your mommy okay I
love that you think I
um listened to her or listened to Megan
with my mom I didn't admittedly I just
like sent her the link so she could
listen to it because I I mean I still BL
I am I am
north of 40 years old and if I am
watching like TV with my mom and there
are two people like on scene I like
their tongues coming yeah not with their
tongues dancing together I think oh my
gosh like
I'm watching with my mother
so
um admittedly we didn't listen to it
together the first time but then when we
were getting ready to see Megan we
listened to it together in the car and
normally I am anti-families like being
on their own devices while sharing space
but I actually was quite grateful that
we were each on our own devices so that
I could like feel the music and also not
have to watch my mom or have my mom
watch me
I think though it is really important
that we have
that we have Megan and we have
other women who are so unapologetically
claiming their whole selves
claiming theirselves as as artists
As Leaders as deserving of center stage
and also claiming their sexuality and I
think that that is far more important
than whatever like embarrassment that I
should have gotten over probably a 12
and not Harbor at 42.
um and I'm really grateful that we are
living in a time where we have more and
more women who are feeling comfortable
being their whole selves yeah yeah yeah
that's absolutely right
you didn't know this but you are being
graded and that was a A plus answer
you said that you were struck by how
Unapologetic Megan the stallion is in
her Joy right right do you feel like you
have had to apologize for your joy over
the course of your career well I think a
lot of people have wanted me to and
sometimes I was sort of grudgingly uh
willing to say well you know I'm sorry
if you know that offended you but I
think
in politics it's different I mean
there's a
you know there's a constant tension
between somebody in politics who really
is always trying to you know be as open
and effective as possible but knowing
you're being literally judged all the
time and so you kind of are editing
yourself and that that's that's what I
regret yeah oh yeah yeah I would know
what that friggin feel like
but some people are not apologetic and
some people are unedited
you know but but Amber think about you
know how many times the three of us but
I also imagine every woman sitting in
this audience tonight you know has had
some variation of
why do you smile so much ooh or wow that
was a loud laugh yeah
or you thought that was funny
um
and you should just keep smiling and
laughing and finding the world funny
when it is
yeah
I get your lapis too loud once a day
from everyone with ears
so many women who you interviewed talked
about misogyny and you've both been in
public life for decades how have you
seen misogyny evolve well look I mean
it's been around since literally the
beginning of time and women have had to
cope with it and you know our progress
has been too slow but forward moving and
then a couple of things have happened
recently where there is this really well
organized well-funded effort to turn the
clock back on women and to you know
double down on the judgment and of
course with the Supreme Court's uh
decision double down on you know
depriving women of making uh their own
choices having their own rights but so
much of this has gotten worse because of
social media I mean it's one thing to
confront you know sexism and and
misogyny in person that's painful and
you you kind of get strategies to deal
with it but when you have an organized
uh effort online to put women down to
bully women you know if you're well
known and you've been around you know
you kind of go oh come on get a life but
if you're a young girl and the people
who are you know attacking you or
criticizing you or bullying you
um you know are people maybe in your
school or your neighborhood and they're
not doing it to your face but they're
kind of laughing at you on social media
or you know showing contempt for you
that's painful and and so I think in a
lot of ways and Chelsea has said this
everybody now leads a public life
similar to what we have led for a long
time because everybody's on social media
yeah I mean I think Amber
um it's it's in many ways the same
Playbook of time immemorial to try to
kind of force women some sometimes
through bullying sometimes through you
know legal means you know into smaller
spaces so that we you know know our
place
think that what is different today
is what young young girls and young
women have to confront on social media
you you think about
you know a 12 year old girl for whom
like her phone may be the most
consistent part of her life like she
gets up in the morning like she checks
her phone she goes to school like on the
bus looks at her phone and between
classes looks at her phone you know
after school looks at her phone after it
after school activity looks at her phone
goes home looks at her phone looks at
her phone before she goes to bed and we
know there's such pervasive bullying and
harassment of girls online and so then
it's painfully not surprising that
depression and anxiety and suicidation
are skyrocketing among young people
especially young girls and we have to do
more to protect kids in this country
yeah yeah
thank you
[Music]
you thought you were going to interview
your little friends but turns out the
Clinton's taking y'all to church
there have been some huge
incomprehensible news events in America
over the past several years and many of
them have cut us completely off guard
but sometimes a news event happens that
one of us did see coming and that one of
us is usually Hillary Clinton
don't believe me then please enjoy this
segment called I'm not going to say I
told you so but
[Applause]
according to the Brennan Center for
justice Russia's efforts to meddle in
U.S elections have become more Brazen
over the past few years I'm not going to
say I told you so
but the Kremlin meaning Putin and the
Russian government
are directing
the attacks the hacking on American
accounts to influence our election
yeah I remember saying that yeah
according to the Huffington Post the
statement headband is a show-stopping
fashion accessory
so I'm not going to say I told you so
but invest in headband
[Applause]
this has been I'm not gonna say I told
you so but
[Applause]
we
got
them
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]